POLONG LIN: In this
video, we'll show you
how you can predict user
churn for your gaming apps
using Google Analytics
4 and BigQuery ML.
My name is Polong Lin, and
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
MINHAZ KAZI: I'm Minhaz Kazi,
and I'm a developer advocate
for Google Analytics.
If you're a mobile
game developer,
a potential challenge for
you could be user retention.
With so many games and
apps to choose from,
keeping users interested
in your product
and enabling them to come
back can be really difficult.
According to a study in
2019, most mobile gamers
see only 25% retention
for users after 24 hours.
That means on average, three
out of four users will churn.
They'll first use their
app, and then after a day,
they'll stop playing.
So the question is, if
I'm mobile game developer,
how do I reduce churn?
Polong, you have experience
with machine learning.
Can that help here?
POLONG LIN: Absolutely.
At a high level, you
can use machine learning
to predict which of
your users are going
to churn based on
how they're behaving
in the app and their
demographic information.
Once you have the predictions
of who's likely to turn,
you can then target those users
who are perhaps on the fence
to incentivize them to come
back to the app or game,
or make the game just a bit
more rewarding for them to play.
Predicting each user's
propensity to churn,
that's where machine
learning can help us.
MINHAZ KAZI: User's
propensity to churn.
That sounds interesting.
Maybe we can apply this
to a real life example.
We have a small little
game called Flood-It!
that's available both on the
App Store and Google Play Store.
Can we identify
users' propensity
to churn for that app?
POLONG LIN: Certainly.
As long as you have
the behavioral data,
you can build machine
learning models
to predict user propensity to
perform any specific behavior
like churn, or making
in-app purchases,
or sharing the game with a
friend, just as examples.
MINHAZ KAZI: So
here's a scenario.
We have this
Flood-It! app and we
can use usage data from there.
My goal is to identify
specific users who
are likely to churn and
then try to retain them.
I can, for example,
through Firebase,
send notifications
to these users,
or customize the game to
be extra rewarding to them.
Through Google Analytics,
I can segment the users
and analyze different
likelihoods of churn
and do marketing campaigns, or
through other marketing tools
tie together with email or
other marketing campaigns.
So Polong, how am I going to
use machine learning to do this?
POLONG LIN: Hold on.
There are a couple
of steps in order
to get to these
activation scenarios.
Let's walk through
all the required
steps in reverse order.
So you had just talked about
the last step, which is using
the predictions for activation.
In order for that
to happen, you'll
need a churn prediction
model to give you
these predictions on
each user's likelihood,
or probability to churn.
And you can build this
machine learning model
using BigQuery ML.
But to create this
model, you'll need
to first have prepared the
data in the right format
for the machine learning model.
So we call this step
data preprocessing,
which is done in BigQuery.
So that brings us
to the first step,
which is making sure you have
your data ready in BigQuery.
MINHAZ KAZI: Great.
That fits in nicely since
we can use Google Analytics
4 to measure usage data
for the Flood-It! app.
We can just export that
usage data into BigQuery.
POLONG LIN: Minhaz, could
you tell us a little bit
about Google Analytics 4?
MINHAZ KAZI: If you're
not already familiar,
Google Analytics 4,
or GA4, is the newest
edition of Google Analytics.
It allows you to
measure user engagement,
not just for websites,
but also for apps.
GA4 uses an event-based model.
Usually, when the user or
the app does something,
that's an event.
If you're an app
developer who's already
been using Google
Analytics for Firebase,
you can be rest
assured that it's
the same data model as GA4.
What's new with
Google Analytics 4
is that any user, free or
paid, can now export the GA4
data into BigQuery.
POLONG LIN: And exporting
data to BigQuery
is really interesting,
because with BigQuery,
which is the data
warehouse on Google Cloud,
you can analyze terabytes
of data in seconds.
And you can also train
and deploy machine
learning models, as you'll
learn in this video.
So if you're a
marketing analyst,
you can train and deploy
machine learning models
just by writing SQL without
any additional programming
languages.
So Minhaz, how would a
Google Analytics user
export their data to BigQuery?
MINHAZ KAZI: I can log onto
the Google Analytics 4 property
and go to the Admin section.
Then click on BigQuery Linking.
On the right hand side, we will
see that, for this property,
no link has been
created to BigQuery.
So we can click on link.
Then it'll ask for which
BigQuery or Google Cloud
Platform Project to link it to.
If you haven't used BigQuery
before, at this point,
you'll just need to set up
an account on Google Cloud
platform and select the
appropriate project.
We'll select our project.
And then click next.
For our analysis, we'll
use the daily export.
After you've reviewed and
submitted your expert options,
GA4 will start exporting the
event data for this property
to the selected
BigQuery project.
After a day or two, you should
start seeing the daily event
data in the events table.
In the BigQuery UI, we can
click on the Preview tab,
and it'll show us what the
event export data looks like.
It shows you the unique
event that occurred
at a specific time stamp.
You also get the event name
and additional information
about the event and
event parameters.
For example, in
the first row, it
looks like the event was a level
complete quickplay by the user.
So now that we have our GA
data in BigQuery, Polong,
what's our next step?
POLONG LIN: Well, in
order for the machine
learning algorithm to
train the model properly,
we need to pre-process
the raw GA4
data to be in the right format.
This is an example of what
an ideal format might look
like for the training data.
Specifically, every
row need to be
represented by a single user
along with a label of churned 1
or 0.
We also want to include features
that can help the model learn,
specifically the user's
demographic information,
and any sort of behavioral data
such as the number of times
they open the app within
a certain time period.
So the way this works in
this data preprocessing stage
is, first, we'll need
to identify users
and the churned label,
process demographic features,
and process behavioral features.
Then, we'll combine them
together as the training data.
With the training data
ready, we can then
move on to building the
churn prediction model.
So the first step is
making sure we have
a solid definition of churn.
Now, your definition
of churn may vary here.
You may want to predict churn
after one day, one week,
or simply whether or not they
will churn up to the first 30
minutes of installing the app.
And that definition
is entirely up to you
to decide what makes
sense for your app.
For us, we chose to define
churn as the following.
After 24 hours of a user's
first engagement with the app,
the users who never came
back we called churned.
Those who come back after
24 hours, we can say they
returned.
That means, given
all the user data
that we have, we want to say,
based on the user information
within the first 24 hours
of them using the app,
can we predict if they
will churn or return?
MINHAZ KAZI: But hold on,
what about those users who
use the app and then
within just a few minutes
they decide that it's not
the app for them at all?
Perhaps those users
aren't worth targeting
with any sort of incentives,
because this wasn't something
they were looking for.
I would prefer to exclude them.
POLONG LIN: That's a good point.
Let's ignore users who left
the app within the first 10
minutes.
We'll call these balanced users.
So when we build the
machine learning model,
we'll only look at
users who didn't bounce.
MINHAZ KAZI: So the
prediction model
will be based only on
the users who spend
at least 10 minutes on the app.
To prepare the user
data in BigQuery,
first we'll create a
bounced label column.
Engagement is an event when the
user interacts with the app.
If the user's last
engagement was
within 10 minutes of
their first engagement,
we'll consider that
the users have bounced.
Bounced users will
get labeled with the 1
in the bounced column.
Otherwise, the value is
0 for all and most users.
Next, we'll create a
label column for churned.
So if the user's
last engagement was
within 24 hours of
their first engagement,
we will consider the
user to have churned.
Otherwise, we know that they
did something with the app
after the first
24 hours, meaning
that they did not churn.
So we give those users a
value of churn equals 0.
So this is what
it looks like now.
One label for churn and
one label for bounced.
POLONG LIN: Perfect.
So in the next section,
we want to process
the demographic information
available for each user.
Minhaz, can you explain
what demographic data
is available in the GA4 data?
MINHAZ KAZI: In
GA events export,
some demographic
data about the user
is recorded automatically,
like the device
language and operating
system, user's browser,
and geographic information.
You can also use user
parameters in GA4 to capture
additional user
demographic data.
For simplicity, we only chose
country, operating system,
and the user's device language.
POLONG LIN: And here, if there
are multiple rows per user,
like if they were in
different countries,
then you can just use
perhaps the most recent
demographic information to
have only one row per user.
So the next step is preparing
the behavioral data.
And this step is
really important
because you want to help the
machine learning model learn
how the user's behavior
in those first 24 hours
predict whether
or not they churn.
Minhaz, what sort of behavioral
data does GA4 capture,
and what fields will
you consider using?
MINHAZ KAZI: As we mentioned
before, each row in GA4 data
is an event.
Some events are automatically
captured by GA4.
There are recorded events for
specific use cases like gaming.
You can also create custom
events, depending on your app.
Let's see what type of events
we have in the flooded data set.
We'll query all the event
names and sort by the account
across the data set.
As you can see, there
are automatically
collected events
like screen_view
and user_engagement.
The other events are
recorded events for gaming,
like level_start_quickplay
and post_score.
From the list, we chose
this subset of events
to be most important
for our analysis.
But you can choose
whichever events
you think might help the
ML model determine who is
likely to churn for your app.
POLONG LIN: So we'd
like this sort of result
where each row is a unique
user ID, and for each user
we have some behavioral stats,
like how many times they engage
with the app, how
many times they
started a level with quickplay
or ended a level with quickplay
and so on.
MINHAZ KAZI: We can achieve this
by counting different events
in different columns
for each user.
POLONG LIN: Now
that we've prepared
our label, the demographic
data, and behavioral data,
we can combine them into
a single table, which
becomes our training data.
MINHAZ KAZI: A quick side
note before moving on
to machine learning.
Let's assume that you have other
demographic or behavioral data
from outside of GA
that you want to use.
For example, the data
could be in your CRM.
You can import that
data into BigQuery
and then join them
using the user ID,
and use that for
training as well.
POLONG LIN: So with the
training data ready, now
we can finally
talk about building
the machine learning
model to predict
churn using BigQuery ML.
In this section, we'll
be using BigQuery ML
to train the churn prediction
model, evaluate the model,
and make predictions
on new users
to get their
probability of churning.
If you're not familiar
with what BigQuery ML is,
it's the ML, or machine
learning functionality,
that's built into
BigQuery by default.
So if your data is stored
in BigQuery, without needing
to move it out, you can use
BigQuery ML to train and deploy
machine learning models
directly using SQL.
You don't need to know
Python, R, or TensorFlow.
You also don't need to set
up any extra infrastructure
because it uses BigQuery's
auto-scaling infrastructure
to train and deploy
your ML models.
So that means you get your
data storage, data analytics,
and machine learning
all built into BigQuery.
There are lots of different
machine learning model types
available with BigQuery ML.
For propensity
modeling, you'll want
to use one of these supported
classification models.
To keep things
simple, we'll stick
with logistic
regression in this video
as it's typically
the fastest to train.
You can always try to improve
your models afterwards,
but this gets you to a
working model quickly.
So to train a logistic
regression model using SQL,
first, you'll need
your training data.
Select star from the table
you just put together.
Next, you'll want to create
a replace model followed
by the project and data set and
the name of the model, which
we've chosen here
to be churn_logreg.
Next, we'll need
to specify that we
want to use logistic
regression as well as setting
the churned column to be
the target variable that we
want to predict.
And that's all you need.
And once the model
is trained, you
can evaluate it in BigQuery ML.
And to do so, you can
use the BigQuery UI,
which shows you the
evaluation metrics
when you select the
model you've trained.
You can see the metrics
like log loss, ROC AUC,
precision, recall, accuracy, F1
score, and some visualizations.
You can also evaluate the
model using select star
from ML.EVALUATE and
then the model name.
If you create
multiple models, you
can use something like
ROC AUC or F1 score
to compare your models, with
better models having scores
closer to 1.0.
And depending on
your needs, this
is where you could be iterating
between training the model
and evaluating the model to
try to improve your model
performance.
There are various approaches
to improving models.
You can try a
different model type,
such as boosted tree classifier,
deep neural networks,
or even auto ML
tables, all which
are supported in BigQuery ML.
You can also try to select
different features, or more
features, or engineer new
features out of existing ones.
And, of course, you
can also try tuning
some of the hyperparameters
of your models.
To learn more, check
out the documentation.
MINHAZ KAZI: Great.
So now with the
model created, how
do we make predictions on who
might actually churn or return?
POLONG LIN: You
can use select star
from ML.PREDICT followed by
the model and the data you
want to make predictions on.
Note that, for the
test data, it should
have the same columns as you
had in the training data.
We can see what the model
predicted in the first column,
but this isn't actually
what we are looking for.
For propensity
modeling, we actually
want a probability of how
likely someone is to churn,
some value between 0 and 1.
So for this, we'll need to
extract out the probability
from the third column called
predicted_churned_probs.prob
for when the label
is equal to 1.
To do so, you can extract
the probability of churn
for each user using
this SQL query.
Now that we have the
user's propensity to churn,
how do you use these
predictions for activation?
Minhaz?
MINHAZ KAZI: To get the
data into an usable state,
we can either-- we did
directly from BigQuery,
or export it into Google Cloud
Storage, or GCS, as CSV files.
This query will export
the selected columns
into a CSV file in a GCS bucket.
We can use either the BigQuery
data, or the exported CSV file,
in different ways depending
on how the [INAUDIBLE] works.
For example, Firebase can
directly import from BigQuery,
whereas external marketing tools
might need to use CSV files.
In GA4, you can
use the data import
feature to import the predicted
values as a user property.
And then the user
property can be
used to create segments
and remarketing lists.
If you're using
Firebase for your app,
you can also import the
predictions back into Firebase
to tailor the user experience
using Remote Config,
or send notifications
to the user using Cloud
Messaging and In-App Messaging.
You might also use
other external tools
to run marketing campaigns,
like sending out emails
to motivate users to return.
Using the steps
described in this video,
we should be able to
do the activations
and finally increase the
number of users retained
for the Flood-It! app and reduce
the number of users churned.
POLONG LIN: Great.
So to recap, we showed you
how to export your GA4 data
into BigQuery,
how to pre-process
the churn label, demographic
data, and behavioral data
to get the training data in
a proper format in BigQuery.
Then, we talked about how
to train, evaluate and make
predictions, using BigQuery ML.
And finally, we
covered a few ways
to use the predictions
for activations.
If you'd like to
follow the steps,
you can check out the blog
post, or the GitHub notebook,
by going to the links in
the video description below.
Thanks for watching.